[Music]
to other news now tensions in the Horn
of Africa have escalated since Ethiopia
signed a maritime deal with the
Breakaway region of somal land earlier
this year the agreement gives landlocked
Ethiopia access to the sea in exchange
for Addis Ababa recognizing Somali
land's Independence the deal has angered
Somalia well joining me live here in the
studio is the president of the federal
republic of Somalia Hassan she muhamud
thank you very much for being with us
sir we have plenty of questions for you
starting with this one you've called e
ethopia an enemy you have recalled your
Ambassador in Ethiopia you have ruled
out mediation with Addis unless they
pull the plug on this deal so how do you
expect this crisis to be resolved then
well uh first of all uh thank you for
having me here and uh then uh it was not
Somalia who created this problem
Ethiopia has created this problem they
are the ones who initiated claiming that
they will take an Annex part of of
Somalia to their country and they don't
say they're annexing they say it's a
commercial deal no no it is not the
ethopia has H commercial interests in
Somalia there in berbera they use
berbera port and they have stake of 19%
even and the ownership of the of service
of Pera and the place where they are now
saying is just few kilometers away few
few few hundred kilomet away from Pera
there's no need for that whatever it is
let us assume that they need another
port and this is what we have been
discussing for a couple of months ago
the issue is not will Ethiopia access to
the Sea they are free to access
throughout Somalia where in everywhere
in Somalia but the question is how how
do they wanted to access the Sea by
annexing part of Somalia and changing
the borders of Somalia this is what's
going on right now it is not a
commercial it is an annexation of
territory so as you know Ethiopia say
says it's not annexation they say it's
also not a formal recognition of the
sovereignty of Somali land they say it
is a commercial deal and I just want to
reminder of viewers of what this
potential deal is the memorandum of
understanding between Ethiopia and
Somali land is that they would rent a 20
kilm stretch of Coastline in somal land
for half a century for 50 years for
commercial purposes and for a military
Port as well what is the part of
that that that that angers Somalia first
of all Somalia is a independent and
sovereign state when such deals are
taking place it is the federal
government of Somalia who has a
legitimate right this thing to be
discussed not a breakaway or not a
region of Somalia at all and above all
uh Commercial and Military base mix it
together and doing one
thing that's one the other thing if it
is a a 20 kilm strip of land in the
coast only how that strip of land and
how that Port is going to be connected
to Ethiopia by passing through
Somalia that's another one the other one
it is in public domain Ethiopia said we
do this in exchange of recognition we
recognize somal land that's a public and
that's official and they said they
didn't say only one time the the Prime
Minister said the Minister of Foreign
Affairs said the National Security
advisor said many other leaders in
Ethiopia said so the recognition is
there but they I'm sorry but they have
walked that all the way back Somalia has
they have said this is not an official
recognition of the sovereignty of Somali
land I we don't have that yet it's you
who have that no they put it on no they
put it on Twitter No the Twitter is not
the way communicate between states have
have you spoken to the Ethiopian Prime
Minister then no why not why do I speak
because he's taking part of my country
and he's claiming we are not equal
Partners when he said I do not recognize
Somalia I recognize somal land which was
part of Somalia
who am I talking to him he's talking to
somal land how does this get resolved if
there's no communication between you and
Ethiopia he has to you know Somalia has
not initiated this problem it's Ethiopia
has initiated it is in their the poll is
in their Court they have to open the
means of the conducive environment to
communicate and to negotiate and to
dialogue it is up to them it's not us so
what do you say to Ethiopia I would like
to say Ethiopia we are neighbors
we are not neighbors by choice we have a
history long long history
known and uh this thing has not happened
in the last more than thousand year that
Somalia and Ethiopia was living together
as people we have a some difficult
histories but I'm not going back to that
history which is difficult but now in
21st century L the Ethiopia recognizes
the sovereignty the territorial
integrity and the political independence
of Somalia the federal republic of
Somalia then we are two partners we can
negotiate everything it toia can have
access they can have deals with us
everything but not the way they are H
approaching now that that's not the way
the modern world Works have you spoken
to the leadership in somal
land 1 January is the time whenou was
signed on 27 December and 28th December
we were having a dialogue discussion in
jibuti and we have a very good
environment and very
good discussion on us and even when that
conclusion was ended prime minister ABIA
appreciated and uh he said you this is a
good step for taken towards the right
direction to me he said to me but the
next day he signed that agreement yeah
so indeed you were with the leaders of
Somali land two three days before that
memorandum of understanding was signed
did they are you saying then that they
kept you in the dark about what they
were about to do yes they never
mentioned we have been discussing how to
unite Somalia not how to give part of
Somalia to Ethiopia no this was not the
subject of discussion the subject of
discussion was the unity of Somalia how
we unite and how we address the
Grievances of the past and all this that
was the discussion what are you asking
Ethiopia to do and what happens if
Ethiopia goes through with this
memorandum of understanding this
deal look look one thing is very
Ethiopia has no right to do
that diplomatically legal it has no
right to do but what if they do it well
that is another case let us hope that
they will not do it this is a puse of
land that belongs to Somalia and so
Somalia will never yield whatever
pressure that comes on it we will keep
claiming our territory and we will take
it back whatever it so far Ethiopians
they didn't come into Somalia yet and we
hope that they will
not if they come in then that would be a
problem at a different level you
traveled around the region recently you
went to Egypt on Sunday you met with the
Egyptian president uh Mr Ali now he had
very harsh words against Ethiopia and he
said they should not try us meaning they
shouldn't try Egypt especially um if
they are challenging a brother by which
he meant uh Somalia he hinted
essentially that Egypt or that's what it
sounded like that Egypt would be welcome
would be willing to come to somalia's
military aid did you discuss military
action with thepan pres Somalia is part
of of the Arab League and in the part in
the Arab League there is a chapter in
the chapter that says that the attack of
one country is the attack of the rest of
the countries in that organization so
Somalia does not need to have a deal
with any Arab country because that is a
mandate to each and every Arab country
number one number two Somalia and Egypt
has a history collaboration of history
for a long time even if before we become
independent in
1956 when the canal SU war was there
Somalia as a people they were supporting
with Egypt and then all the way many
times Somalia has got into difficult
Egypt to support the support does not
mean boots on the ground okay that's my
question because I understand the
history but my question is did You
discuss potential military action no no
the we have not discussed it h military
act Egyptian Military coming to Somalia
and and we believe that the problem has
not reached there yet and that's why
he's saying warning and all this don't
do it please Okay this may sound like a
naive question but is there perhaps a
win-win scenario here between Somalia
and Ethiopia where the two countries can
cooperate Ethiopia wants access to the
Sea as by the way all landlocked
countries do Somalia on the other hand
is fighting the armed group al-shabab
we'll get to that a little bit more in a
moment there are thousands of ethiop
Ethiopian troops on Somalian territory
as part of that ongoing effort isn't
there a way perhaps that the two
countries can can come to some kind of
understanding to refuse this crisis I
have to repeat it again ER the question
between Somalia and Ethiopia is not how
Ethiopia will Ethiopia access to the Sea
that's not a question we want Ethiopia
to have an access to the sea but the
question is how Ethiopia is going to
have that access to the Sea that's
number one and that we if ethopia is
ready we are ready to discuss but
grabbing a piece of land we are not
ready for that regarding the issue of
al-shabab al-shabab is not threat to
Somalia only al-shabab is a Regional
threat is a continental threat and said
it has been this shabab has been
interfered in Ethiopia in Kenya in
Uganda in jouti and in Europe even so
shabab it just happened that they are in
Somalia but they are not problem to
Somalia only so Ethiopia but mainly but
mainly to Somalia well let us say except
mainly but
Ethiopia number one they were there as a
part of the Mandate of the African Union
Mission there there and then they were
there bilaterally when there is a trust
and good relationship such thing can
happen we have bilaterally agreed to
come in and support Somalia that's where
they are how they are in
Somalia but now people who have
been contributing their and adding their
plot together to defend a common to
defeat a common enemy now comes back
again and this is a
backbiting specifically on the issue of
the fight against al-shabab this has
been going on for more than 15 years
this is something that already plagued
your country Somalia during your first
term as president a number of years
ago they haven't been defeated so the
question is can they be defeated yes
they can and we have proven that they
can more than 50% of the territory they
were controlling they are not
controlling today they have been
squeezed into a smaller area than than
they were a year ago than today and we
keep contining this operations is going
on as we are speaking here and mainly
these operations are done by Somali
National Army and Somali Defense Forces
are doing these operations most of them
so we believe based on the experience
and the successes that we made in the
last one and a half year we believe that
we can defeat al-shabab militarily it
may take some time ideologically but
military we will definitely defeat them
the fight has been going on since 2006
and as I mentioned it lasted during the
entirety of your first term as as
president of Somalia this was in the
2010s is there a point where you would
consider negotiations with al-shabab
instead of a military defeat when they
are ready we are ready but they are not
ready they don't believe a somal have
you tried no they don't they are this is
a public domain they don't believe a
somal state so how do I negotiate with
someone who basically does not believe a
state in Somalia this is the problem the
real problem is these people they have a
global agenda they don't have a local
agenda this is not Taliban who has a
local agenda in Afghanistan these people
they don't have local this is Al they
have a global agenda how do I negotiate
with the problems of Muslim problems
that exist in Europe or in somewhere
else this is for us it's our local
president the president of the federal
republic of Somalia Hassan shik Muhammad
thank you so much for joining us here in
the studio thank you very much thank you